I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello, hello. Hi, everyone. We're here today to talk about The Banker. The Banker? But it's more than just The Banker. There's a lot of stuff wedged in this one. It's true. Mm-hmm. We will discuss. We will. It was Season 6, Episode 14, written by Jason Kessler and directed by Jeffrey Blitz. Here's your summary. An investment banker visits the Scranton branch
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安杰拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。我们是好朋友。现在我们为你带来了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有亲历者才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。哈喽，哈喽。大家好。我们今天来聊聊《银行家》。《银行家》？但它可不止是《银行家》。这一集里塞了超多内容。确实。嗯哼。我们会讨论的。我们会的。这是第六季第十四集，由杰森·凯斯勒编剧，杰弗里·布里茨执导。剧情梗概如下：一名投资银行家造访斯克兰顿分公司
to perform a due diligence check to verify that there are no hidden liabilities for whomever buys Dunder Mifflin. Because remember, Dunder Mifflin is being sold. Yeah. This prompts Michael and his employees to pull out all the stops to try to prove their worth. Mm-hmm. Well, as you guys know, Jen and I are rewatching the show for the first time in years. And I forgot that this was a clip show. It is. It was kind of a big deal back then for Networks. Sam, you have a whole theory about this. I do. I wonder if this is a time period thing. I remember clip shows were very popular at that time. Like, for big things like Seinfeld and Friends, like, in the middle of a season would go, hey, remember all this? And you
进行尽职调查，以核实无论谁买下邓德米夫林都不会有任何隐藏的负债。因为记住，邓德米夫林正在被出售。没错。这促使迈克尔和他的员工们使出浑身解数来证明自己的价值。嗯哼。好吧，正如你们所知，珍和我已经有很多年没有重温这部剧了。我竟然忘了这是一集精编回放集。确实是。这在当时对各大电视台来说可是件大事。山姆，你对此有一套完整的理论。我确实有。我在想这是否是一个时代的产物。我记得精编回放集在那时非常受欢迎。比如像《宋飞正传》和《老友记》这样的大剧，在播到一季中间的时候会说，嘿，还记得这些吗？然后你会
go, yes, I do. I'm a fan. Yeah. Yeah. You know, I read a few articles online about it and people were confused. They were like, why are they having a clip show? And then people either thought it was really well done for a clip show or they just hated it. Well, my fast fact number one is going to cover some of this. Okay. We got a fan question from Andy J. in Battleground, Washington and Hannah C. in Portland, Oregon, who said, clearly this episode is largely flashback clips, but I'm wondering what was the reason behind it? Had you gained new viewers and this was a way to bring them up to speed or was everybody else just busy filming other stuff? I went to Randy Cordray. What did Randy say? Randy
说，当然记得，我是粉丝。对。对。你知道，我在网上读了几篇关于它的文章，人们都很困惑。他们会想，为什么他们要搞一个精编回放集？然后人们要么觉得作为精编回放集它拍得很好，要么就是讨厌它。好吧，我的第一个冷知识将涵盖其中一部分。好的。我们收到了来自华盛顿州战地镇的安迪·J和俄勒冈州波特兰市的汉娜·C的粉丝提问，他们说，显然这一集大部分都是闪回剪辑，但我想知道背后的原因是什么？是因为你们获得了新观众，而这是一种让他们快速了解情况的方式，还是其他所有人都在忙着拍摄别的东西？我去找了兰迪·科德雷。兰迪怎么说？兰迪
said this clip show was a request from the network. Sam, you were right. Yeah. Oh my gosh. Listen to you, Chuckle. Honestly thrilled. So the idea was that a clip show would be much less expensive to produce. Uh-huh. That it would save the network money in the overall budget for the show that year. But Randy pointed out that all of the actors were under weekly contracts. So even though this episode only took us two days to shoot, instead of five, they still had to pay the cast for the full week. And the same thing went for the writer and the director. Plus they had to pay a fee to every guest actor and director of every clip that got used in the clip show. There are so many. Yes. So Randy said in the end,
说这个精编回放集是电视台的要求。山姆，你猜对了。耶。哦，天哪。听听你，笑得。老实说，我挺激动的。所以当时的构想是，精编回放集的制作成本要低得多。嗯哼。这能在当年的整体预算中为电视台省下钱。但兰迪指出，所有的演员签的都是周薪合同。所以尽管这一集我们只花了两天而不是五天就拍完了，他们仍然得支付演员整整一周的薪水。编剧和导演也是如此。此外，他们还必须向精编回放集中使用的每一个剪辑片段的客串演员和导演支付费用。这里面有好多人。是的。所以兰迪说，最后，
it cost as much as a regular episode. Oh, now this episode did forward along some story. You know, we do have this banker who's coming to review the company because we're being sold. And so those scenes obviously were newly written. The script for this episode was only 14 pages long. It was written by Jason Kessler, who was a member of our production staff, and he was our script coordinator seasons one through four on the office. And he played flower delivery man in Valentine's Day. Yay, Jason. Yes. So nice. Oh, he was the loveliest. My fast fact number two, Sam, you might like this. I did do a little bit of a deep dive on the use of flashbacks and clip shows in film and television. I do really
它的花费和一个普通的一集差不多。哦，不过这一集确实推动了一些剧情。你知道，确实有这个银行家因为公司要被出售而前来审查公司。所以这些场景显然是新写的剧本。这一集的剧本只有14页长。它是杰森·凯斯勒写的，他是我们制作团队的一员，在前四季里担任我们的剧本统筹。他在《情人节》里扮演了送花员。太棒了，杰森。没错。太好了。哦，他最可爱了。我的第二个冷知识，山姆，你可能会喜欢。我确实对电影和电视中闪回和精编回放集的使用做了一些深入的研究。我真的很
like this. Yay. I'm very curious because I had a screenwriter in college who had a theory about flashbacks. Go first. Oh, you go. All right. Well, according to Taste of Cinema, the best use of flashbacks in a movie belongs to Citizen Kane with Godfather Part Two coming in second. But this article said that Citizen Kane introduced many techniques that were fairly new to the film world at the time, like the use of depth of field and this fragmented storytelling that went back and forth between present and past different time periods. The website Industrial Scripps said that if you are writing a film and you want to study great uses of flashbacks, they suggest studying the following films. Memento, Forest Gump,
喜欢这个。耶。我非常好奇，因为我在大学里曾遇到过一个对闪回有一套理论的编剧。你先说。哦，你来。好吧，根据“电影品味”网站的说法，电影中闪回用得最好的是《公民凯恩》，《教母第二部》紧随其后。但这篇文章说，《公民凯恩》引入了许多当时电影界相当新颖的技术，比如景深的运用，以及在现在和过去不同时间段之间来回切换的碎片化叙事。工业剧本网站表示，如果你在写一部电影并且想要研究闪回的精彩运用，他们建议研究以下几部电影：《记忆碎片》、《阿甘正传》、
or Titanic. Yeah, because Titanic's told basically through flashback. Yes. Yeah. According to this site, all the stories of these films are told mostly from the perspective of flashback. It also noted films like Kill Bill, Old Boy, and Eternal Sunshine of the Spotless Mind, which are some of my favorite movies. So perhaps I like a flashback movie. You do. I guess so. Before show, these are not flashbacks. This is actually a clip show, which is something different because these flashbacks are not part of overall storytelling. So it's a different category. All of these flashbacks are set up as sort of Toby looks off in the distance recollecting, right? Yes. But they are not forwarding any new story through their flashback.
或《泰坦尼克号》。对，因为《泰坦尼克号》基本上是通过闪回讲述的。是的。是的。根据这个网站，这些电影的所有故事主要都是从闪回的角度讲述的。它还提到了《杀死比尔》、《老男孩》和《美丽心灵的永恒阳光》等电影，这些都是我最喜欢的电影。所以也许我就是喜欢闪回电影。你确实喜欢。我想是的。节目开始前，这些可不是闪回。这其实是一个精编回放集，这是完全不同的东西，因为这些闪回并不是整体叙事的一部分。所以这是一个不同的类别。所有这些闪回的设定都类似于托比看着远方在回忆，对吧？是的。但它们并没有通过闪回推动任何新剧情的发展。
Right. So that's why it enters the column of clip show. Wikipedia says that a clip show is an episode of a TV series that consists primarily of excerpts from previous episodes. They are also known by their nickname Cheaters. Okay. It's a cheater show. Here comes my screenwriting professor moment. Ready? Okay. I wrote a pilot. I had it start with a big old flashback and I got it back from my professor and he was like, you cheated at the top. The flashback was a cheat. Tell the story. I was like, well, damn it. It did make it a lot easier. Well, I don't know. I think industrial scripts would disagree with your professor because there are times when the use of a flashback is very powerful. I agree. But I guess not for the very
对。所以这就是为什么它被归入了精编回放集一栏。维基百科说，精编回放集是电视剧的一集，主要由以前剧集的节选组成。它们还有一个昵称叫“作弊集”。好吧。这是一部作弊剧。接下来是我的编剧教授时刻。准备好了吗？好的。我写了一个试播集。我让它以一个巨大的老派闪回开场，然后我从教授那里拿回了作业，他说，你在开头作弊了。那个闪回是一个作弊手段。直接讲故事。我想，好吧，该死。这确实让事情变得容易多了。好吧，我不知道，我想工业剧本网站会不同意你教授的看法，因为有时候闪回的使用是非常有力量的。我同意。但我想在第一句话中讲故事的最初阶段大概不行吧。我们看到了日出闪回。什么？你的剧本才写了四个词。
first time you tell a story in the first sentence. We see a sunrise flashback. What? We're only four words into your script. Now here's something I found interesting about clip shows. I guess they are often run before a series finale as a way to remind viewers about the series or sometimes they are made to help fulfill the episode requirements for when a show is sold to syndication. It's all about the money guys. Follow the money. All about the money. The first use of a clip show appears to be the serial movie Robinson Caruso of Clipper Island from 1936 for Republic Films. So they were supposed to make 12 chapters of this story. Each one was about 30 minutes long, like the length of a TV show, but it played in theaters. But I guess there was some
现在，关于精编回放集，我发现了一件有趣的事。我想它们经常在系列大结局之前播出，作为一种提醒观众注意该剧集的方式，或者有时它们是为了帮助满足将剧集卖给电视网联播时的集数要求。这一切都是为了钱，伙计们。顺着钱找。全是为了钱。精编回放集的第一次使用似乎是1936年为共和国电影公司拍摄的系列电影《快船岛的鲁宾逊·克鲁索》。所以他们本应制作这个故事的12章。每一章大约30分钟长，就像一集电视剧的长度，但它是在电影院上映的。不过我猜当时有一些
bad weather and they had to shut down filming. So writer Barry Shipman was forced to create two extra chapters to help recoup the lost production costs. So now he had to do 14 chapters in less time with less budget. So to do this, he created what is considered to be the first recap, which was Chapter 11, Agents of Disaster. He wrote a few original scenes where the characters recount their adventures to date and then they use stock footage from previous chapters instead of shooting new sequences. Well, Republic Films was so thrilled by this little cheat that the recap chapter became standard procedure moving forward. How about that? So I think maybe Barry Shipman started it all? Don't know. Sounds like it maybe. Maybe. I just have been delighted watching you
恶劣的天气，他们不得不停拍。因此编剧巴里·希普曼被迫创作两个额外的章节来帮助弥补损失的制作成本。所以现在他必须在更短的时间内、用更少的预算做出14章。为了做到这一点，他创作了被认为是第一份回顾总结的内容，也就是第11章《灾难特工》。他写了一些原创场景，让角色们回顾他们至今的冒险经历，然后他们使用了前几章节的现成素材，而不是拍摄新的镜头。好吧，共和国电影公司对这个小作弊感到非常兴奋，以至于回顾总结章成了以后标准的操作流程。怎么样？所以我想也许是巴里·希普曼开创了这一切？不知道。听起来可能是。也许吧。我看着你
retell all of this. I wish you guys were here with me because she's so tickled by it, guys. She's so tickled. She looks absolutely delighted at her findings. It's adorable. Well, I have two more little facts about this that I will share. Don't stop now. Community, the TV show community, they did two fake clip shows. They took and did a clip show format, but when they flashed back, it was all newly shot material. They're so clever. I know. They are clever. And finally, this episode, The Banker, was our only clip show of the entire office series. Well, I wonder if the powers that be saw the comment boards because people were not happy that we did a clip show. Well, they also got the accounting spreadsheet and saw they
复述这一切简直乐坏了。我真希望你们能和我一起在这儿，因为她太觉得好玩了，伙计们。她太逗了。她对自己的发现看起来绝对欣喜若狂。太可爱了。好吧，关于这个我还有两个小事实要分享。现在可别停。社区，电视剧《社区》，他们做了两个假的精编回放集。他们采用了精编回放集的格式，但当他们闪回时，全部都是新拍的素材。他们太聪明了。我知道。他们很聪明。最后，这一集《银行家》是我们整个办公室系列中唯一的精编回放集。好吧，我想当权者们可能看到了评论区，因为大家对我们做了一个精编回放集很不高兴。好吧，他们也拿到了会计电子表格，发现他们
saved no money. That's right. That's right. All right. Fast fact number three is a fan question from Corey P. in Oak Harbor, Washington. Please tell us everything about working with David Constable, who, of course, was playing Gail in Breaking Bad when this episode came out. In this episode, he plays The Banker. Now, David was the third cast member of The Wire to appear on the office, but you probably recognize him. I mean, this guy has been in everything amazing. He's a phenomenal character actor. He's good luck. You should cast him in everything good and he's good. In fact, we will be casting you in Mom Detectives, David. David, get ready. Get ready. But he has been in billions, suits, Breaking Bad,
根本没省下钱。没错。没错。好的。第三个冷知识是来自华盛顿州奥克兰港的科里·P的粉丝提问。请告诉我们所有关于和大卫·科斯塔贝尔合作的细节，当这一集播出时，他当然正在《绝命毒师》中扮演盖尔。在这一集中，他扮演银行家。现在，大卫是《火线》中第三位出现在办公室的演员，但你很可能认出他来。我的意思是，这家伙出演过所有精彩的作品。他是一位杰出的性格演员。他是吉祥物。你应该让他出演所有优秀的作品，而且他真的很棒。事实上，我们将让你在《妈妈侦探》中出演，大卫。大卫，准备好。准备好。但他曾出演过《亿万》、《金装律师》、《绝命毒师》、
Better Call Saul and damages. He was Rain Wilson's very good friend. Yeah. From when they were younger and I reached out to him. I asked him how he got his role in the office and here's what he had to say. The story with me in the office is that I had known Rain Wilson since college and we became lifelong friends. And we had created this play called The New Bozina. And that's actually what brought us out to Los Angeles. We had been doing it in New York and we had done it off Broadway at the Cherry Lane Theater. And then we came to Los Angeles to do the show and to also see if we could sell it and make it into a TV show or movie or something, which we ended up doing, selling it, but not making it. And around that time, we were out there, Rain and in fact,
《风骚律师》和《法网裂痕》。他是雷恩·威尔逊的好朋友。是的。从他们年轻的时候起，我联系了他。我问他是怎么得到办公室里的这个角色的，他是这么说的。我和办公室的故事是这样的，我从大学起就认识雷恩·威尔逊了，我们成了终身的好朋友。我们创作了一部名为《新博齐纳》的戏剧。这实际上就是把我们带到洛杉矶的原因。我们一直在纽约演出，并在樱桃巷剧院进行过外百老汇演出。然后我们来到洛杉矶演出，同时也看看我们能否把它卖掉并拍成电视剧或电影之类的，最后我们的确卖了，但没拍成。大约在那时，我们在那里，雷恩和事实上，
all of us got auditions to go in for the pilot of the office, which we did. So it was incredibly fun. So I had auditioned for the pilot and all of us, we kind of knew on some level, we all kind of knew Rain was the best suited for Dwight. And sure enough, he was. So none of us got it, but Rain did. And we were all incredibly excited because none of us had a nickel between us. So then throughout the years, like I would go in and audition for a bunch of things. And Alison always looked out for me and it was very exciting to be able to think that I could get on that show. And it was I really, really, really wanted to rain was always every season he would ask Alison, you'd be like, can you put them on? Can you put them on? And so they finally got me on the show.
我们所有人都得到了去为《办公室》试播集试镜的机会，我们也确实去了。所以这极其有趣。所以我为试播集试了镜，我们所有人都，我们在某种程度上心知肚明，我们都觉得雷恩是最适合德怀特的人。果不其然，他确实是。所以我们都没得到角色，但雷恩得到了。我们都无比兴奋，因为我们当时口袋里连个硬币都没有。所以在随后的几年里，比如我会去为一个接一个的角色试镜。艾莉森一直很关照我，能觉得自己有机会加入那部剧让人非常激动。而且我真的很想、很想、很想加入，雷恩每一季都会问艾莉森，你会说，你能让他上吗？你能让他上吗？所以他们终于让我上了这部剧。
Well, I remember David coming to visit the set as Rain's friend. I had lunch with him. And in fact, I ended up doing a movie with him. I did this movie called solitary man. And I played Michael Douglas's daughter and David played my husband. So I was so thrilled when David was then joining us as an actor. He's so good. He's super funny. Well, that's so great. I'm so glad we got to reconnect with him. Well, I have a few other clips that I'll share later on in the episode. But maybe we should take a break. Let's take a break. And when we come back, I have some deleted scenes from the clip show. Wow. Well, this episode starts with a Michael talking head. He explains that Dunder Mifflin is being sold. But first, an investment banker must
嗯，我记得大卫作为雷恩的朋友来片场参观过。我和他一起吃过午餐。事实上，我最后还和他一起拍了一部电影。我拍了一部叫《孤独的人》的电影。我扮演迈克尔·道格拉斯的女儿，大卫扮演我的丈夫。所以我得知大卫作为演员加入我们时感到非常兴奋。他太棒了。他超级搞笑。好吧，太棒了。我很高兴我们能和他重新联系上。好吧，我在这一集后面还会分享一些其他的剪辑片段。但也许我们该休息一下。我们休息一下吧。当我们回来时，我有一些来自精编回放集的删减片段。哇。好吧，这一集从迈克尔的单采开始。他解释说邓德米夫林正在被出售。但首先，一位投资银行家必须
stop by and sign off on the Scranton branch. So in true Michael fashion, he has decided to judge the place up a little. We got a fan question from Josephine E in New York, New York. Michael's hair looks so different in this episode. It's kind of light and flat. Was Steve filming something at the time that affected his hairstyle? Such a good catch. Yes, Josephine. If you watch this episode, you might see Steve's hair changing from scene to scene. And I'll tell you why. We shot this episode over two days. One day was before we went on a break for Steve to do a movie. And the other was when we came back from Steve doing the movie. He has bookend hairstyles. So in this particular instance, we had just returned from our winter
顺道拜访并对斯克兰顿分公司进行签字确认。所以出于迈克尔的典型风格，他决定把这里稍微打扮得漂亮一点。我们收到了来自纽约州纽约市约瑟芬·E的粉丝提问。迈克尔的发型在这一集里看起来很不一样。有点浅而且很扁平。史蒂夫当时在拍什么影响他发型的东西吗？问得太好了。是的，约瑟芬。如果你看了这一集，你可能会看到史蒂夫的发型在不同的场景中发生变化。我会告诉你原因。我们花了两天时间拍摄这一集。有一天是在我们休息让史蒂夫去拍电影之前。另一天是我们从史蒂夫拍电影回来之后。他的发型是首尾呼应的。所以在这个特定的例子中，我们刚刚结束了我们的寒假
hiatus. And Steve had been shooting dinner for schmucks. And he had a very, very, very short haircut for that. Our hairdresser, Kim Ferry, did an interview with OfficeTelly.com, where she said she tried really hard to recreate a Michael Scott look. But the hair was so short. She went on to say, you will see gradually over the next few weeks, his hair will grow out and be more like the old Michael Scott. She said, but we did shoot the banker out of order. So you might see that his hair goes from shorter to longer. There you have it. Well, now we're going to see all the ways that Michael is trying to fancy up the office. Eric Ward, the investment banker, is greeted, first of all, by Computron. It's a virtual helper. And Michael comes zipping out
休假。史蒂夫一直在拍摄《笨蛋晚宴》。为此他留了一个非常、非常、非常短的发型。我们的发型师金·费里接受了OfficeTelly.com的采访，她在采访中表示，她努力尝试重新打造迈克尔·斯科特的造型。但头发实在是太短了。她接着说，你会在接下来的几周里逐渐看到，他的头发会留长，变得更像以前的迈克尔·斯科特。她说，但我们确实是打乱顺序拍摄《银行家》的。所以你可能会看到他的头发从较短变成较长。就是这样。好吧，现在我们将看到迈克尔为美化办公室所做的一切努力。投资银行家埃里克·沃德首先受到电脑人的迎接。这是一个虚拟助手。而迈克尔踩着赛格威呼啸着
of his office on a Segway. Yes. And then Andy suddenly announces that we are now the official paper supplier for the NFL. Mm hmm. And Pam is introduced as their international sales consultant and greets Eric in three different languages. We got a fan question from Eminé in London, UK. How many takes did it take for Steve to get through the scene where he is on the Segway? I mean, he must have crashed into Pam's desk or reception at least once. My memory is that Steve was very good on the Segway. This was my same memory, too, that he was actually really zippy on that thing. Well, Randy told us that our transportation coordinator, Jesse Dutchover, contacted the Segway company, and they were super excited to participate in our episode.
冲出他的办公室。是的。然后安迪突然宣布我们现在是NFL官方纸品供应商。嗯哼。潘被介绍为他们的国际销售顾问，并用三种不同的语言向埃里克打招呼。我们收到了来自英国伦敦埃姆内的一位粉丝提问。史蒂夫拍他骑赛格威那个场景拍了多少次才过？我的意思是，他肯定至少撞过一次潘的桌子或前台。我的记忆是史蒂夫在赛格威上表现得非常好。这也是我的记忆，他实际上在那东西上开得非常快。好吧，兰迪告诉我们，我们的交通统筹杰西·达切弗联系了赛格威公司，他们对参与我们的拍摄感到超级兴奋。
They gave us two Segways to practice with, along with a service technician and a company rep, and Steve practiced. That's why he was so good in the scene. I guess these Segways were out in the parking lot for two days. Anyone could check them out if they wanted to. I did not try it. Angela, did you try it? Oh, no. No, no, no. No. I don't know why I was like, I'm not getting on that thing. But then Steve came out of his office so effortlessly, and it looked so fun that I was like, dang it, now I wish I had tried it. I know. But after we shot with it, they went away. Yeah. You had to do it preemptively. Right. Randy shared with us that it's really pretty easy to use them. He said you use your body English, and it's like you lean forward or back, and then the machine
他们给了我们两辆赛格威用来练习，还配了一个服务技术人员和一个公司代表，史蒂夫进行了练习。这就是为什么他在那一幕中表现得那么好。我猜这两辆赛格威在停车场放了两天。任何人只要想都可以借来试骑。我没有试。安杰拉，你试了吗？哦，没有。不，不，不。不。我不知道为什么我当时想，我才不上那个东西呢。但后来史蒂夫毫不费力地从办公室出来，看起来太好玩了，以至于我想，该死，现在我真希望自己当时试一下了。我知道。但我们在它上面拍完之后，它们就被拿走了。是的。你必须先发制人地去做。没错。兰迪跟我们分享说，这东西用起来其实相当容易。他说你得运用你的身体语言，就像你向前或向后倾斜，然后机器
just sort of senses how to move. What if you don't trust your body English? Exactly. Randy also shared with us that his hometown of Jacksonville, Oregon has a two-hour Segway tour of their historic town. Now, I would do that. What? I would do that. That sounds so cool to me. Like Josh and I, my husband and I, we've done vacations where we rent the electric bike and we tour something on the bike. Uh-huh. So fun. Maybe we should go visit Randy and do a Segway tour. Oh my gosh. You had me at visit Randy. I would love to see him. He said in the summer, he looks out and he just sees tons of tourists roaming around Segways. We could be one of those tourists. Oh, I wanted to point out also in the scene at one minute forty seconds, the golf picture is still on the wall. I know.
就会感应到如何移动。如果你不信任自己的身体语言怎么办？确实。兰迪还跟我们分享说，他的家乡俄勒冈州杰克逊维尔市有一个为期两小时的赛格威历史小镇之旅。这个我会去。什么？这个我会去。这听起来对我很酷。就像乔希和我，我丈夫和我，我们去度假时租过电动自行车，然后骑着自行车去参观某个地方。嗯哼。太好玩了。也许我们应该去拜访兰迪并进行一次赛格威之旅。哦，天哪。你一说拜访兰迪就把我吸引住了。我很想见他。他说夏天的时候，他放眼望去就能看到成群的游客在赛格威上闲逛。我们可以成为那些游客之一。哦，我还想指出，在1分40秒的那个场景里，高尔夫画还在墙上。我知道。
I am so confused. I had no idea that this painting was missing for so long. I mean, we're going on like eight episodes now. Yeah. It's bonkers to me. As the scene continues, we learn from a Pam talking head that there's no one left in New York, so Michael is now Dunder Mifflin's highest ranking employee. Let that sit with you for a minute. Now, we had a fan catch from Catherine H in Denver, Colorado, who says, aren't Jim and Michael the same rank? Oh, good catch. I don't know. Why is it Pam recognizing Jim's position in this office? I have to say, she sort of continues to forget his position of authority in Dunder Mifflin. I know. She has to keep reminding herself. The next thing that happens is that Michael greets
我太困惑了。我根本不知道这幅画消失了这么久。我的意思是，我们现在已经拍了大概八集了。是的。这对我来说太疯狂了。随着场景的继续，我们从潘的单采中得知纽约已经没人了，所以迈克尔现在是邓德米夫林职位最高员工。让这个事实在你脑海里沉淀一会儿。现在，我们在丹佛的凯瑟琳·H有一个粉丝发现，她说，吉姆和迈克尔难道不是同一级别的吗？哦，好发现。我不知道。为什么潘要承认吉姆在这个办公室里的职位？我不得不说，她某种程度上继续忘记了他在邓德米夫林拥有的权威职位。我知道。她必须不断提醒自己。接下来发生的事情是迈克尔问候了
Stanley, who is now young and fit. That's right. It's fake Stanley. Pam says, for the record, I'm not on board with fake Stanley, but I get it. I personally think that Michael should have had a fake creed. A fake creed? What about a fake Meredith? Yes. These are our true wild cards in the office. Yeah. But anyway, fake Stanley was played by Kenny Cooper. He's been on a ton of stuff. He's been on the TV series The Board, me, you and him, the Kominsky method. This is us, the after party and the Oscar nominated film Selma. He trained at UCB Improv Theatre in LA. And according to his bio, he was an all conference football player in college. He's been in everything. Talented, athletic. Oh my gosh. Well, Jenna, there was more to this
斯坦利，他现在又年轻又健美。没错。那是假斯坦利。潘说，郑重声明，我并不赞成假斯坦利，但我理解。我个人认为迈克尔应该弄一个假克里德。一个假克里德？弄个假梅丽迪丝怎么样？是的。这些才是我们在办公室里的真正王牌。是的。不过不管怎样，假斯坦利是由肯尼·库珀扮演的。他演过超级多作品。他演过电视剧《董事会》、《我和你和他》、《柯明斯基理论》、《我们这一天》、《聚会之后》以及奥斯卡提名电影《塞尔玛》。他在洛杉矶的UCB即兴剧场受过训。根据他的个人简介，他在大学里曾是全明星橄榄球运动员。他什么都演过。才华横溢，运动细胞发达。哦，天哪。好吧，珍娜，迈克尔的这次
office tour by Michael. Some of it actually got deleted. Yes. Even though the banker is a clip show, we have deleted scenes. Two of them really made me laugh. You have to hear this. Michael, on his segue, goes up to front reception, of course, to try to impress Eric Ward and ask Aaron for his messages. Any messages? Yes. The governor called. He said, thank you. Well, tell him I told you so. What's the second message? The Treasury called. Dunderman Flint paper is being used for counterfeit currency. That's how good it is. That's the price you pay when you're the best. Amazing. Everyone calls Michael the governor, the Treasury of the United States. This continues. Michael writes his segue into the conference room and they have it set up kind of like
办公室参观还有更多内容。其中一些其实被删掉了。是的。尽管《银行家》是一个精编回放集，但我们依然有删减片段。其中两个真的让我大笑。你必须听听这个。迈克尔骑着他的赛格威来到前台，当然是为了试图给埃里克·沃德留下深刻印象，并向艾伦询问他的留言。有什么留言吗？是的。州长打来电话。他说，谢谢。好吧，告诉他我早就告诉过你了。第二条留言是什么？财政部打来电话。邓德米夫林纸张正被用于制造假币。这就是它的品质有多好。当你成为最棒的时，这就是你付出的代价。太惊人了。每个人都叫迈克尔州长、美利坚合众国财政部。接下来的场景。迈克尔把他的赛格威骑进会议室，他们把那里布置得有点像
a Google think tank room. Okay. There's a big ideas board. In fact, there's a banner that says idea jam. And Ryan has a ball and he's tossing it against the wall, just sort of like spewing stupid ideas and Oscar weighs in. And in the corner, Angela is sitting next to a box of kittens nitting them clothes. Oh, you have to hear it. Ah, this is our creative think space. Google has one of these. What if we ran the whole thing backwards? Total paradigm shift. We spin it and we flip it. Look at that. See what the little one's doing. She's making some sweaters for the kittens. Sometimes they get cold at night. So we try to help them out. That's what's great about this place. Got something for everyone, whether you like cutting edge thinking or pilgrim
谷歌的智囊团房间。好的。有一个巨大的创意板。事实上，上面还有一个写着“创意碰撞”的横幅。瑞恩手里拿个球，把它朝墙上扔，只是那种狂吐愚蠢的创意，奥斯卡也插话了。在角落里，安杰拉坐在一箱小猫旁边，给它们织衣服。哦，你必须听听这个。啊，这是我们的创意思考空间。谷歌就有一个这样的地方。如果我们把整件事反过来运行呢？彻底的范式转变。我们旋转它，我们翻转它。看那个。看那个小家伙在做什么。她正在给小猫织毛衣。它们晚上有时会冷。所以我们试着帮帮它们。这就是这个地方棒的地方。这里应有尽有，无论你喜欢尖端的思考还是朝圣者般的
values. Help yourself to a kitten, Eric. You cannot have a kitten. Give him a kitten. You have enough. Angela David copied truck while back. Oh my gosh. And I remember Jenna, I worked with so many cats on this show, but this was a day on set that I had like six kittens. And everybody wanted a kitten. They were so cute. Oh my gosh. Well, I know from my experience with kitten rescue, there is just nothing cuter than a box of kittens. There isn't. I'm sorry, a box of kittens, it's even cuter than a box of puppies. You can come for me if you want, but I'm going to hold firm on this. A box of kittens is the cutest thing. Well, I will have to put in our stories on Office Ladies pod, just the scene with the basket of kittens because it's so cute. Well, I can't wait to see
价值观。自己拿只猫吧，埃里克。你不能养一只猫。给他一只猫。你已经够多了。安杰拉，大卫不久前还抄过卡车。哦，天哪。我记得珍娜，我在这个剧里和超多猫合作过，但这是片场我有大概六只小猫的一天。每个人都想要一只小猫。它们太可爱了。哦，天哪。好吧，根据我救助小猫的经验，世上没有什么比一箱小猫更可爱的了。确实没有。不好意思，一箱小猫，它甚至比一箱小狗还要可爱。你们想喷我的话尽管来，但我坚信这一点。一箱小猫就是最可爱的东西。好吧，我得把跟那一篮子小猫相关的场景发到我们的“办公室女士”播客快拍里，因为实在太可爱了。好吧，我等不及要看
it. Angela, do you know how to knit? Were you fake knitting? Was that fakey knitting? That was fakey knitting. Did anybody give you a lesson? No. So someone had knitted something and then you were just moving the little, what are they called? The needles. The needles. Yeah. It was so funny to me because Phyllis had to knit. She had a basket of like yarn and knitting needles by her desk, the entire run of the show. Yeah. And supposedly this was something her character would do. And they gave her a little tutorial, but that was early in the show. I think by this time, they're like pretending it. Right. Let's do it. My great grandmother used to crochet. Oh yeah, mine too. And I want to take it up. You know, I love doing that kind of stuff. You know, I made
了。安杰拉，你会织毛衣吗？你那是假织吗？那是假织吗？有人教过你吗？没有。所以有人织了点东西，然后你就在那儿挥舞那些小，它们叫什么来着？针。织针。是的。我觉得特别搞笑的是，菲莉丝得织毛衣。整部剧拍下来，她的办公桌旁一直放着一篮子毛线和织针。是的。而且据称这是她这个角色会做的事。他们教过她一点基础，但那是剧集刚开播的时候。我想到了这个时候，他们就是在假装了。对。我们上吧。我曾祖母以前会钩织。哦，是的，我奶奶也是。我想学那个。你知道，我喜欢做那种东西。你知道，我给我
my kids Christmas stockings and I love embroidery and things like that, but I really want to get into the crocheting. Oh, for sure. I actually crocheted with my grandmother. She taught me how. Mine too. And I did part of a blanket. Like I didn't finish it. So then it was just sort of a scarf. Right. But kind of a lame scarf. But I feel like that's something I would take up with you. Oh my gosh. Two ladies who crochet. The next episode of Mom Detectives. One of the needles went missing. What happened to it? Well, in crocheting, you only use one needle. Oh, it's that needle. I just solved it. Oh my gosh. It's not missing at all. It's not missing. You have what you need. I have everything I need. And episode ends credits.
孩子们做了圣诞长袜，我喜欢刺绣之类的手艺，但我真的很想学钩织。哦，当然。我其实是跟我奶奶一起学的钩织。她教我的。我奶奶也是。我织了毯子的一部分。呃，我没织完。所以它最后基本上就变成了一条围巾。对。但有点像一条逊毙了的围巾。不过我觉得这会是我跟你一起学会做的事。哦，天哪。两个会钩织的女士。《妈妈侦探》下一集。其中一根针不见了。怎么回事？嗯，在钩织里，你只用一根针。哦，是那根针啊。我刚才破解了。哦，天哪。它根本没丢。它没丢。你拥有你需要的东西。我拥有我需要的一切。然后播放片尾演职员表。
Well, back to the episode. Eric, the banker explains that the only reason he came today was to check out the warehouse and speak with HR. That's it. He doesn't need all this other computron and the segue and the think tank. He doesn't need it. But Michael insists I want to show you around. I mean, I made a reservation at Cooper Seafood because it has the best lobster. But then Computron disagrees. You know who makes the best main lobster? Mouliam in Tel Aviv. We got a fan question from YLF in Tel Aviv. I myself am from Tel Aviv and thought you might appreciate a mini dive on Mouliam. Mouliam was a restaurant that specialized in fish and seafood that was considered to be one of the best restaurants in Israel. Its name is a play on words.
好吧，回到这一集。银行家埃里克解释说，他今天来的唯一原因就是去仓库看看并和人力资源部谈谈。就这样。他不需要所有这些乱七八糟的电脑人、赛格威和智囊团。他不需要这些。但迈克尔坚持要带你四处转转。我的意思是，我在库珀海鲜餐厅订了位，因为那里有最好的龙虾。但接着电脑人提出了不同意见。你知道谁做的缅因龙虾最好吗？特拉维夫的穆里亚姆。我们收到了来自特拉维夫YLF的粉丝提问。我自己就来自特拉维夫，觉得你们可能会喜欢对穆里亚姆的小小深入了解。穆里亚姆是一家专门经营鱼类和海鲜的餐厅，被认为是以色列最好的餐厅之一。它的名字是一个双关语。
It could mean either in front of a sea or sea muscle. It opened in 1995 but was burned to the ground in an accident in July of 2015 and it has never reopened. By the way, I never got to go there even though I only lived 10 minutes away and the first time I ever watched the banker it was very shortly after the restaurant had burned down and I literally yelled at the TV because I was so annoyed that Dwight got to have their lobster and I didn't. Well, I did appreciate that mini dive. I did not know it was a real restaurant. I did. Oh, not only did I know but I have been there and it's one of the best meals I've ever had. Really? Yes. I was working on a commercial that actually shot in Tel Aviv. I know that's crazy but I was there and you know how I love
它的意思既可以是在海前，也可以是海贻贝。它于1995年开业，但在2015年7月的一次事故中被烧为平地，从此再也没有重新开业。顺便说一句，尽管我只住在离那儿10分钟远的地方，我却从来没去过，而且我第一次看《银行家》的时候，正好是在那家餐厅被烧毁后不久，我当时简直在电视机前大喊大叫，因为德怀特能吃到他们的龙虾而我吃不到，这让我太恼火了。好吧，我很感激那个深度的背景介绍。我以前不知道那是一家真正的餐厅。我知道。哦，不仅我知道，我还去过那儿，那是我吃过最棒的饭菜之一。真的吗？是的。我当时正在拍一个实际上在特拉维夫拍摄的商业广告。我知道这很疯狂，但我确实在那儿，而且你知道我有多喜欢
to make friends on the airplane, Jenna? I do. I love a friend on the plane. On my flight there, I sat next to this wonderful woman named Erit and she was telling me all the places to go and she was like, you must go to dinner with me. There's this amazing restaurant in Tel Aviv. It's on all the like the best restaurants lists and it's called Mulyam and as it turns out, it was only like a five minute walk from my hotel. So I was like, oh my gosh, yes. She got us a reservation. I met her there. It was one of the best dinners I've ever had. I actually found video on my phone of my walk there because it was like on this like wharf, you know? It literally is facing the sea and I found video of my walk there that night.
在飞机上交朋友吗，珍娜？我知道。我很喜欢在飞机上交朋友。在我去那里的航班上，我坐在一个叫埃里特的 maravilhosa（美妙的）女士旁边，她告诉我所有该去的地方，她说，你必须跟我一起去吃晚饭。特拉维夫有一家超级棒的餐厅。它在所有最佳餐厅榜单上，名字叫穆里亚姆。结果证明，它离我的酒店只有大约五分钟的步行路程。所以我当时想，哦，天哪，太棒了。她帮我们订了位。我在那儿见到了她。那是我吃过的最棒的晚饭之一。我甚至在手机上找到了我那天晚上走过去的视频，因为它在那种码头旁边，你知道吗？它真的是面朝大海的，我找到了那天晚上走过去的视频。
It was so beautiful. The food was amazing. I was so sad to hear that it burned. Did you eat the lobster? I ate seafood. I can't remember what I had but I can tell you this. I remember so vividly what a great meal it was. I texted my friend Tess who went with me and she was like, oh my god, it's like one of the best meals we've ever had. I was like, I know. What did we have? She was like, I can't remember. I didn't even order. The chef just sent things over. Wow. Yeah. I have some of those restaurants that I've eaten at or some of those meals that I've had that are just the best meals I've ever had. Yeah. I had a bowl of ramen that I got in a train station in Tokyo and I have been chasing that taste ever since I ate it.
太美了。食物太棒了。听到它被烧毁的消息我很难过。你吃龙虾了吗？我吃了海鲜。我不记得我吃了什么，但我可以告诉你这一点。我非常清晰地记得那是多么好的一顿饭。我给和我一起去的我的朋友苔丝发了短信，她说，哦，天哪，这简直是我们吃过最棒的饭菜之一。我说，我知道。我们吃了什么？她说，我不记得了。我甚至都没点菜。主厨直接把菜端上来了。哇。是的。我有几家这样的餐厅，我在那里吃过饭，或者说我有过几次这样的用餐体验，那真的是我吃过最棒的饭菜。是的。我在东京的一个火车站吃过一碗拉面，自从吃过之后，我一直在追寻那个味道。
Like I came back to the States and I'm always ordering ramen from restaurants and I cannot not get it back. Yeah. It makes me want to go back to this train station just to eat that broth. Good food. Good food is like one of those memories you have instantly, like smell, taste. Interestingly enough, the other food I'm always chasing, I had a soup when I was in Thailand that again, I haven't been able to find this taste ever since. I guess I love a good broth is what I'm realizing. I guess you do. I sometimes just think like it will come over me about my mom's gravy. My mom's gravy is so good. Yeah. She uses like things left over in the skillet. I don't even know what it is. It's so good. My dad barbecues a hamburger. Like no one else has
就像我回到美国后，总是从餐厅里点拉面，但我再也找不到那个味道了。是的。这让我真想回到那个火车站就为了喝那一碗汤。美食。美食就像那些转瞬即逝的记忆，比如气味、味道。有趣的是，我一直在追寻的另一种食物，我在泰国喝过一汤，同样地，从那以后我就再也没能找到那个味道。我想我意识到我很喜欢一碗好汤。我想你是吧。我有时会突然想起我妈妈做的肉汁。我妈妈做的肉汁太好吃了。是的。她用的是锅里剩的东西。我甚至不知道那是什么。太好吃了。我爸爸烤的汉堡。就像没人能
been able to barbecue a hamburger. We are recording this at lunchtime. I think we're both hungry. Well, you started talking about all this food. I know. And you know what I have waiting for me in the fridge out there is just some yogurt and it's making me sad now. I have a granola bar in my purse. It's so lame. I want all of the stuff we just talked about. I do too. Okay. Where are we in the banker? Well, where we are is that Michael is going to introduce Eric to Toby. Quote Toby. Exactly. It's actually Dwight sitting in Toby's chair and Michael explains that he bought himself some time because he put a copy of Best American Mystery Stories 1999 in Toby's favorite bathroom stall. Well, I was intrigued. Is this a real book or is this a made up book? Now, we know that Toby
烤出那样的汉堡。我们是在午餐时间录制这一集的。我想我们俩都饿了。好吧，你开始聊所有这些好吃的。我知道。你知道我在外面的冰箱里等着我的是什么吗，只有一些酸奶，现在这让我很难过。我钱包里有一根燕麦能量棒。太逊了。我想要我们刚刚聊过所有那些好吃的。我也想。好吧。我们在《银行家》的什么进度了？好吧，接下来是迈克尔把埃里克引见给托比。引用托比的话。没错。实际上是德怀特坐在托比的椅子上，迈克尔解释说他给自己争取了一些时间，因为他在托比最喜欢的那个洗手间隔间里放了一本《1999年美国最佳悬疑故事集》。好吧，我很好奇。这是一本真正的书还是一本虚构的书？现在，我们知道托比
likes mysteries. That's been established. It turns out that this is a real anthology series. The Best American Mystery Anthology Series started in 1997. It is a collection of essays and short stories. It would come out annually. I think recently they changed the name to Best American Mystery and Suspense Stories. But this Best American Anthologies, they go way back. It started in 1915 and is still published today. Wow. That is over 100 years. That's awesome. So in addition to short stories and mystery, there are seven of these serials still in publication. They are Best of American Essays, Best American Science and Nature Writing, Best American Travel Writing, Best American Science Fiction and Fantasy. Angela, I thought you might
喜欢悬疑。这是已经确定的。事实证明，这是一部真正的选集系列。《美国最佳悬疑故事选集系列》始于1997年。它是散文和小说的合集。它每年都会出版。我想最近他们把名字改成了《美国最佳悬疑与惊悚故事》。但这些《美国最佳选集》历史悠久。它始于1915年，至今仍在出版。哇。那已经有一百多年了。太棒了。除了短篇小说和悬疑，这些连载中仍有七个在出版。它们是《美国最佳散文》、《美国最佳科学与自然写作》、《美国最佳旅行写作》、《美国最佳科幻与奇幻》。安杰拉，我想你可能会
like that. Might be a future gift you see from me. And Best American Food Writing. There are a whole bunch of others that have been discontinued. There was a Best American Recipes, a Best American Spiritual Writing. This one, I was really curious about. Best American Non-Required Reading. Oh, so it's not on any of the list at school. I guess. Best American Comics, Best American Sports Writing and Best American Infographics, which is basically a book full of charts and diagrams. Well, Angela, I ordered Best American Infographics. Oh my God. Of course you did. It's so interesting. I bet. Well, remember when we talked about how Florence Nightingale made the pie chart go viral? Yes. I mean, this is a whole book of pie charts and graphs.
喜欢这个。这可能是你以后会收到的我送你的礼物。《美国最佳美食写作》。还有一大堆其他已经停刊的。曾有过《美国最佳食谱》、《美国最佳灵性写作》。这个，我真的很好奇。《美国最佳非必读读物》。哦，所以它不在学校的任何书单上。我猜是的。《美国最佳漫画》、《美国最佳体育写作》以及《美国最佳信息图表》，基本上是一本充满图表和图解的书。好吧，安杰拉，我订购了《美国最佳信息图表》。哦，天哪。你当然订了。太有趣了。我敢打赌。好吧，还记得我们讨论过南丁格尔是如何让饼图风靡一时的吗？是的。我的意思是，这是一整本饼图和图表的书。
This sounds like a great book to have in your bathroom. I think it would make a great bathroom book. Well, that brings me to a little journey that I took, Jenna. Oh, really? After this Michael talking head, I was just curious. Like, what are the best books to read while you're on the toilet? Is there a way to research that question? Oh, yeah. In fact, there were many articles. I'm going to just bring up one. According to Sarah Johnson from Barnes and Nobles Read Section, here are five books to read in the bathroom. Okay. The Groucho Letters by Groucho Marx. Groucho Marx's correspondence with everyone from E. B. White to his phone company gives insight into the brilliance and humor he brought to every aspect of his life.
这听起来是一本很棒的厕所读物。我觉得它会是一本极好的厕所读物。好吧，这就把我带到了一次小小的旅程中，珍娜。哦，真的吗？在这个迈克尔的单采之后，我只是很好奇。比如，你在马桶上时读什么书最好？有没有办法研究这个问题？哦，有的。事实上，有很多文章。我只挑出一篇。根据巴诺书店阅读版块的萨拉·约翰逊的说法，以下是五本适合在厕所里读的书。好的。马克思兄弟的《马克思兄弟书信集》。马克思兄弟与从E·B·怀特到他的电话公司等所有人的通信，让人得以一窥他在生活的方方面面所展现出的才华和幽默。
Hmm. Next one. The Areas of My Expertise by John Hodgman. I love John. Yeah. He's a friend. He's smart. He's funny. In this book, John is deadly serious about educating you on a range of useless topics. Oh, order that for me now. I know. Poor Richard's Almanac by Benjamin Franklin. It's a timeless compilation bursting with wisdom, puns, and satire. Who knew? I didn't know. Awakening Loving Kindness by Pema Chodron. This book teaches you how to love yourself without harboring anger or embarrassment and how to feel at peace with the world and whatever it throws at you. That sounds like a good book to read anywhere, anytime. I know. And lastly, Toilet Paper Origami by Linda Wright. Okay. I guess that's if you want to do more than
嗯。下一本。约翰·霍奇曼的《我的专业领域》。我爱约翰。是的。他是朋友。他很聪明。他很搞笑。在这本书里，约翰非常认真地就一系列毫无用处的各种话题对你进行教育。哦，现在就帮我订购那本。我知道。本杰明·富兰克林的《理查德穷人 almanac（历书）》。这是一本永恒的汇编，充满了智慧、双关语和讽刺。谁知道呢？我不知道。佩玛·恰卓的《唤醒慈悲心》。这本书教你如何爱自己，而不心怀愤怒或尴尬，以及如何与世界以及它抛给你的任何东西和平相处。听起来无论何时何地都是一本好书。我知道。最后，琳达·赖特的《厕纸折纸》。好吧，我想如果你想做的不仅仅是
read. It says, why not learn to do something impressive while you're seeing a man about a dog? That's what the reviewer said. My search did not end there. According to a recent U.S. survey, 63% of people read books, magazines, or newspapers on the toilet, but up to 75% take their phone with them. I was going to say, I read a book called Instagram. And then there's another book I read called Twitter. Yeah. Well, that led me to this. I was curious, how long are people sitting on the toilet? Oh, from the website Livestrong.com, it says, checking your phone on the throne can be bad for your butt. Why? Unlike sitting in a chair, which gives you support, your bottom hangs down in the middle of the toilet. Kyle Stoller, a gastroenterologist and a neuro gastroenterologist,
阅读的话。上面写着，当你有事要办时，为什么不学点令人印象深刻的东西呢？评论者是这么说的。我的搜索并没有就此结束。根据最近的一项美国调查，63%的人在马桶上读书、杂志或报纸，但多达75%的人把手机带进厕所。我正想说，我读过一本叫“Instagram”的书。然后还有一本我读过的书叫“Twitter”。是的。好吧，这引导我走向了这一点。我很好奇，人们在马桶上坐多久？哦，根据网站Livestrong.com的说法，在王座上刷手机对你的屁股有害。为什么？与坐在能提供支撑的椅子上不同，你的屁股在马桶中间是悬空的。凯尔·斯托勒，一名胃肠病学家和神经胃肠病学家，
and is the director of the Gastrointestinal Motility Laboratory at Massachusetts General Hospital and an assistant professor of medicine at Harvard Medical School. You guys, Kyle knows what he's talking about. He says, the way you sit on a toilet allows the rectal tissue to relax and fall. Lingering too long on the toilet over a period of time can result in hemorrhoids, getting blocked up, anal fissures, or the worst, your rectum could fall out, your anus. What? Just from sitting on the toilet too long? I mean, clearly for years, right? It's a buildup. It doesn't happen overnight. So basically they said, go in and do your business and then get off the toilet. Don't make a meal out of it. Don't sit out there and read multiple
并且是马萨诸塞综合医院胃肠动力实验室主任兼哈佛医学院医学助理教授。伙计们，凯尔知道他在说什么。他说，你坐在马桶上的方式会让直肠组织放松并下垂。长时间在马桶上流连忘返可能会导致痔疮、堵塞、肛裂，或者最糟糕的是，你的直肠可能会掉出来，你的肛门。什么？仅仅是因为坐在马桶上太久？我的意思是，显然是日积月累的，对吧？这是一个积累的过程。它不是一夜之间发生的。所以基本上他们说，进去办完你的事，然后离开马桶。别把那当成一顿饭。别坐在那儿看好几本
articles. Get in there, read one, get out. Listen, if you want to limit your time on the toilet, what you need to do is have small children because they will not let you stay in there long. No. Okay, they're going to help you get out of there because they're going to immediately need something the minute you go into the bathroom. Truly, they could be totally fine. And then the minute you're like, oh, I got to go to the bathroom, everybody has a question for you. Correct. Yes. So that's what I have to say about reading on the toilet. Don't linger on the loo. Okay. That is our public service announcement for today. Guys, don't stay on that toilet too long because your whole rectum could just fall right out. Oh my lord. Well, I think we should
文章。进去，读一篇，出来。听着，如果你想限制你在厕所里的时间，你需要做的是生几个小孩子，因为他们不会让你在里面待太久。不。好吧，他们会帮你离开那里的，因为你一进浴室，他们就会立刻需要什么东西。真的，他们本来可能完全没事。然后你一说，哦，我得去上厕所，每个人都有问题要问你。没错。是的。所以这就是我对在厕所看书的看法。别在厕所里磨蹭。好吧。这就是我们今天的公益广告。伙计们，别在那个厕所里待太久，因为你的整个直肠可能会直接掉出来。哦，我的天哪。嗯，我觉得我们应该
take a break. I have to pee. Don't stay in there too long, lady. I'm serious. I'm going to time you. We'll be back. So now we are going to get into the portion of this show with the flashback clips. Yes. And for those of you rewatching with us, I have a quiz for you. Oh, do you know how many episodes were used in this clip show? See if you can keep a tally as you rewatch and I'm going to tell you at the end, thank you, Randy Cordray, for helping me with this quiz. Oh, well, I have a little tidbit to share from our writer's assistant, Rob Burnett. He shared a document with us that was used to generate the ideas for these various clips from the various
休息一下。我得去嘘嘘。别在里面待太久，女士。我是认真的。我要给你计时。我们一会儿回来。现在我们要进入这档节目的闪回片段部分。是的。对于和我们一起重看的你们，我有一个小测验。哦，你知道这个剪辑秀里用了多少集吗？看看你在重看时能不能记一下账，我最后会告诉你，谢谢罗恩·科德雷（Randy Cordray），谢谢你帮我完成这个小测验。哦，好吧，我有一个小花絮要分享，来自我们的编剧助理罗布·伯内特（Rob Burnett）。他跟我们分享了一份文档，这份文档是用来为来自各个
episodes. They got their ideas from two places. First of all, the writers were asked to go through the episodes they had written and list some of their favorite moments that might work in a clip show. And then Rob put it all into a document. It is so cool. And then Rob also compiled fan favorite moments from a poll on NBC.com. They had asked people to list their favorite episodes, their favorite quotes, their favorite Michael moments, their favorite Dwight moments, their favorite accounting moments, favorite pranks, favorite party moments, their favorite Jim Pam moments, their favorite romantic moments, non Jim Pam, I thought that was really funny. They're like something romantic, you can't say Jim Pam, their favorite costumes and favorite
剧集的各种剪辑生成创意的。他们的创意来自两个地方。首先，编剧们被要求浏览他们写过的剧集，并列出一些他们最喜欢的、可能适合剪辑秀的时刻。然后罗布把这一切都整理成了一份文档。真是太酷了。然后罗布还整理了 NBC.com 投票中粉丝最喜欢的时刻。他们让人们列出他们最喜欢的剧集、最喜欢的台词、最喜欢的迈克尔时刻、最喜欢的德怀特时刻、最喜欢的会计时刻、最喜欢的恶作剧、最喜欢的派对时刻、最喜欢的吉姆·帕姆时刻、最喜欢的浪漫时刻（非吉姆·帕姆，我觉得这个真的很好笑。他们就像是：来点浪漫的，但不能是吉姆·帕姆）、最喜欢的服装和最喜欢的
webisode moments. And this was how they started to brainstorm what clips to use. This document was really fun to look through. I mean, Jenna, I found this document fascinating. Rob, thank you so much for sharing it with us. You know, I love a fan favorite list. I love it. And according to a poll at NBC.com, there are two I want to share. Here were the top five fan favorite episodes at this time. Okay. Number one, the injury. Yes. You love the injury. I love it. Number two, diversity day. Mm hmm. Number three, stress relief. Number four, dinner party. And number five, casino night. Wow. Yeah. And here were the top five fan favorite quotes at this time, according to this poll on NBC.com. Okay. Number one, any guesses, anyone? I mean, I could guess,
网络剧时刻。这就是他们开始集思广益挑选剪辑片段的方式。这份文档看起来真的很有趣。我是说，珍娜，我觉得这份文档太迷人了。罗布，非常感谢你跟我们分享它。你知道的，我喜欢粉丝最喜欢的榜单。我太喜欢了。根据 NBC.com 的投票，有两个我想分享。当时粉丝最喜欢的五大剧集是这些。好的。第一名，伤势。是的。你最喜欢伤势。我太喜欢了。第二名，多元化日。嗯哼。第三名，压力缓解。第四名，晚宴派对。第五名，赌场之夜。哇。是的。当时粉丝最喜欢的五大台词是这些，根据 NBC.com 上的这个投票。好的。第一名，有人要猜猜吗？我是说，我可以猜，
but I read the document. You can't guess Sam Cassie. Any guesses? I'm known for me. Cassie, you want to take a shot? That's what she said. Yes. That's what she said by Michael Scott. Number two, Bears Beats Battlestar Galactica by Jim. Mm hmm. Number three, I'm not superstitious. Well, maybe I'm a little stitious. So good. Michael Scott. Number four, I hate so much about the things you choose to be. Now that's my favorite. That's such a good one. That's what Michael says to Toby. That's right. And number five, just as you have planted your seed into the ground, I will plant my seed into you. Mm hmm. Dwight Schrute. Those were the fan favorites. I can't believe my all time favorite is just pooping. You know how I be. I can't believe that didn't make.
但我读过那份文档。你不能猜，萨姆·卡西。有人猜吗？我以我闻名。卡西，你想试一下吗？那是她说的。是的。迈克尔·斯科特说的“那是她说的”。第二名，吉姆说的“熊，星际大战，太空堡垒卡拉狄加”。嗯哼。第三名，我不是迷信主义者。好吧，也许我有点迷信。太棒了。迈克尔·斯科特。第四名，我太讨厌你选择成为的那种人了。现在那是我的最爱。这真是一个很好的梗。那是迈克尔对托比说的。没错。第五名，正如你将你的种子播撒进泥土，我也将我的种子播撒进你体内。嗯哼。德怀特·施鲁特。这些就是粉丝的最爱。我简直不敢相信我一直以来的最爱只是拉屎。你知道我是什么样的人。我真不敢相信那没有入选。
That didn't make it in. Yeah. Well, here we go. We're going to get in to some flashback clips because the real Toby has returned to his desk and Eric is going to start his questioning. Yes. His first question to Toby is, does your company have any outstanding liability issues? And then we just see a montage of just Michael, quite frankly, destroying the office and just so many mishaps that happened in the office. Yeah. Well, I thought this was a pretty good compilation. In my little bit of research, I saw that most of these clips came from episodes written by Leon Jean or BJ Novak. I don't know what that says. Yeah, guys, but you guys are writing like dudes like getting in scuffles. I guess so. Another one of the moments in this compilation
那没有入选。好吧，我们这就开始吧。我们要进入一些闪回片段，因为真正的托比已经回到了他的办公桌前，埃里克要开始他的提问了。是的。他对托比的第一个问题是，你们公司有任何未决的责任问题吗。然后我们就看到了一段蒙太奇，坦白说，全是迈克尔在办公室搞破坏，还有办公室里发生的那么多的事故。是的。嗯，我觉得这是一个相当不错的汇编。在我的一点研究中，我发现这些剪辑大多来自利昂·金（Leon Jean）或B·J·诺瓦克（BJ Novak）写的剧集。我不知道这说明了什么。是的，伙计们，但你们写的东西就像是小伙子们在打架。我想是的。这个汇编中的另一个时刻
is that moment when Meredith gets the bat on her head and then Dwight is like suffocating her with a trash bag. That was a pitch from Danny Chun. Well, you know the moment where Angela takes her cat out of a cabinet in accounting and then tosses it into the ceiling to Oscar. Otherwise, no one is safe bandit. That was a fan favorite on NBC.com poll. I think it is a fan favorite. I think so. Well, now Eric is going to ask Toby if the staff is generally happy. Toby sort of laughs. He's basically like, what is happy? I love when you said happy is a funny word. Yeah. I have to say you always know someone is hedging if they like try to redefine the word that you're asking them about. Are they answered with a question? Oh, yes. That's the biggest tell.
是梅雷迪思头上顶着一只蝙蝠，然后德怀特用垃圾袋窒息她的那个时刻。那是丹尼·陈（Danny Chun）的提议。你知道安吉拉把她的猫从会计部的柜子里拿出来，然后把它扔到天花板上给奥斯卡的那个时刻吗。换句话说，没人安全，班迪特。那是 NBC.com 投票中粉丝最喜欢的时刻。我觉得它确实是粉丝的最爱。我也这么觉得。好吧，现在埃里克要问托比员工是否普遍感到快乐。托比笑了笑。他基本上就是：什么是快乐？我太喜欢你说“快乐是一个有趣的词”的时候了。是的。我必须说，你总是知道某人在闪烁其词，如果他们试图重新定义你向他们询问的那个词的话。他们是用问题来回答吗？哦，是的。那是最大的破绽。
Where were you tonight? Where were you? Or what I was thinking of if it's like, where were you tonight? Where was I tonight? Yeah. Oh, did you not hear me? Yes. That's right. The question is, where were you tonight? Exactly. Where was I tonight? Yeah. Where were you tonight? Right. Right. Right. Oh, you're good. You're good at it. So clearly in these series of questions, Toby is trying not to be forthcoming, but the flashbacks tell all. Thankfully, Eric, the banker cannot see all of this documentary footage because in this next series of flashbacks, we're going to see Andy punch the wall and Pam slap Michael and Jim smack Dwight. Phyllis is going to throw the post-its in Angela's face, which by the way, did really hurt. Those
你今晚去哪儿了？你今晚去哪儿了？或者我想到的是，如果像是：你今晚去哪儿了？我今晚去哪儿了？是的。哦，你没听见我说话吗？是的。没错。问题是，你今晚去哪儿了？确切地。我今晚去哪儿了？是的。你今晚去哪儿了？对。对。对。哦，你很擅长。你很擅长这个。所以在这一系列问题中，很明显托比试图有所保留，但闪回说明了一切。谢了，银行家埃里克看不到所有这些纪录片素材，因为在接下来的这一系列闪回中，我们将看到安迪打墙，帕姆扇迈克尔耳光，吉姆掌掴德怀特。菲利斯要把便利贴砸到安吉拉脸上，顺便说一句，这真的很疼。那些
post-its were pointy and hit my face at a fairly high velocity from Phyllis. Now listen, if I'm being critical, I felt like this clip segment was very similar to the last clip segment where he asked about liabilities. Like, I feel like these could have been interchangeable. I don't know. I thought our people happy is a pretty tough lead-in question. And I also kind of question why the banker would need to ask that question. You know what? I have a better question for the banker. What is it? He should have said to Toby, who has the most sass in the office? Oh, I would have loved to have seen clips of sass, right? Give me the sass clips in BC. If you were in charge, we would have had a whole flashback of sass. That's right. The next question Eric is
便利贴很尖，以相当高的速度从菲利斯那里击中了我的脸。现在听着，如果我要挑刺的话，我觉得这个剪辑片段跟上一个他询问责任的剪辑片段非常相似。就像，我觉得这些本可以互换的。我不知道。我觉得“人们快乐吗”是一个挺难的引导性问题。而且我也有点质疑为什么银行家需要问这个问题。你知道吗？我有一个更好的问题要问银行家。是什么？他应该对托比说，办公室里谁最时髦？哦，我很想看到时髦的剪辑，对吧？把时髦剪辑给我，NBC。如果你负责的话，我们就会有一整段关于时髦的闪回了。没错。埃里克接下来要
going to ask Toby is about liability of like harassment. Toby says he doesn't know. He doesn't know. Just flat out doesn't know. And Eric's like, but you're human resources. He's like, I don't know. I don't know. Well, now we're going to get flashbacks of many human resources, violations like Dwight calling out employees, medical conditions, specifically Meredith's hysterectomy. Also, one of my favorites when Michael kisses Phyllis' cheek and says he's worried about getting a bone or? Yes. Or when he tells Pam she can come into his office, but he is changing clothes and has no pants on. We had a fan catch from Christian E in Austin, Texas. There is a clip in this montage from Beach Games. It is the one where Michael says,
问托比的是关于骚扰的责任问题。托比说他不知道。他不知道。直截了当地说不知道。埃里克就像是，但你是人力资源部啊。他说，我不知道。我不知道。好吧，现在我们要看到许多人力资源违规行为的闪回，比如德怀特大声说出员工的医疗状况，特别是梅雷迪思的子宫切除术。还有，我最喜欢的时刻之一，当迈克尔亲吻菲利斯的脸颊并说他担心会有感觉或？是的。或者当他告诉帕姆她可以进他的办公室，但他正在换衣服，没有穿裤子。我们收到了来自德克萨斯州奥斯汀的克里斯蒂安·E（Christian E）的粉丝抓包。这段蒙太奇里有一个来自《海滩运动会》的剪辑。就是迈克尔说，
dip it in the water so it will slide down your gullet more easily. And then everyone says that's what she said. Well, Christian points out, and we pointed out on the podcast, this was a deleted scene. Yes. And also everyone responding was the cast improvising. Now, I believe that this is the only deleted scene clip used in the clip show. Everything else appeared in an episode that aired except for this one. Nice catch, Christian. Toby has this great talking head where he says he doesn't know how he's going to get through this because he doesn't want to lie, but he also really doesn't want to tell the truth. I mean, I just love these scenes between Eric the banker and Toby. I like that Toby is working so hard to defend the company. And when I was trading messages with David,
把它蘸在水里，这样它就能更轻松地滑进你的食道。然后每个人都说“那是她说的”。好吧，克里斯蒂安指出，我们在播客上也指出了，这是一个被删掉的场景。是的。而且每个人回应的都是演员即兴发挥的。现在，我相信这是剪辑秀中使用的唯一一个被删掉的场景剪辑。除了这个之外，其他所有内容都出现在播出的剧集中。干得漂亮，克里斯蒂安。托比有一个很棒的面对镜头独白，他说他不知道自己该怎么度过难关，因为他不想撒谎，但他也真的不想说实话。我是说，我太喜欢银行家埃里克和托比之间的这些场景了。我喜欢托比如此努力地为公司辩护。当我和大卫互发信息时，
I asked him if there was anything he remembered in particular about shooting this episode, and he mentioned these scenes between him and Paul. Here's what he had to say. One of the things that I remember so strongly was I had a scene with Paul, and I wanted so badly to see if I could be drier and even more understated than Paul. And I was, sadly, I couldn't do it. And I've tried my hardest to do it, and I really, really wanted to it because I love Paul's acting, and I thought he was hilarious in the show, and I wanted to see if I could actually go underneath where he was. And as I did it, I realized, oh, no, he has so many other levels that he could even ratchet back. And he did. He smoked me out clearly as we were doing the
我问他是否有什么特别记得的关于拍摄这集的事情，他提到了他和保罗之间的这些场景。他是这么说的。我印象最深的事情之一是，我和保罗有一场戏，我非常想看看我能不能比保罗表现得更枯燥、更低调。结果我确实做到了，遗憾的是，我没能做到。我曾拼尽全力去做到这一点，我真的、真的非常想做到，因为我喜欢保罗的演技，我觉得他在剧里搞笑极了，我想看看我能不能真正做到比他的位置更低。当我这样做的时候，我意识到，哦，不，他还有那么多其他的层次，甚至可以往回收。而他确实做到了。我们在演这场戏时，他显然把我给比下去了，因为当我试图比他更低时，他就会变得更低、更小、更小。在我们拍这场戏的时候，这是一个极其有趣的游戏。
scene because then as I was trying to get below him, he would just get lower and lower and smaller and smaller. And it was an incredibly fun game to try to play as we were shooting the scene. So I have to say, after David said that, I went back and I rewatched the Eric Toby scenes. I feel like I can see it. I feel like I can see them even within one scene, each of them getting smaller and smaller and smaller and smaller. Also, just everything about it, if it's like these two guys trying to outbore each other, I thought it was so great. Their energy and tone was so perfect. I would like to see more of them. Well, now Michael is going to get in on the action. He is going to interrupt Toby and Eric. Yeah, Michael's now going to sit in and basically
所以我必须说，在大卫说完之后，我回去重看了埃里克和托比的场景。我觉得我能看出来。我觉得我甚至能在一场戏中看出他们俩变得越来越小，越来越小，越来越小，越来越小。还有，关于它的所有一切，就像这两个人在试图比对方更无聊，我觉得太棒了。他们的精力和基调是如此完美。我很想看到更多他们的对手戏。好吧，现在迈克尔要介入了。他要打断托比和埃里克。是的，迈克尔现在要坐下来，基本上
almost sabotage what Toby's trying to do by not sharing information. I know. I think Michael is afraid that Toby is going to give away too much, but Toby is doing a good job. I know. Eric wants to know about waste. How are they wasting time and resources at the company? Yes. Well, obviously, there's tons of time being wasted at Dunder Mufflin. Well, this was the prompt so that we could show pranks. Yes, all the gem and Dwight pranks. Correct. When you watch this compilation, it is really fascinating to consider that Dunder Mufflin is the top branch in the company. The next question Eric has is about retirement age. Is anyone near the retirement age for Dunder Mufflin? Jenna, I had never thought about this. Like, Creed must be at retirement age.
几乎是通过不分享信息来破坏托比试图做的事情。我懂。我觉得迈克尔害怕托比会泄露太多，但托比做得很好。我知道。埃里克想了解浪费情况。他们在公司里是如何浪费时间和资源的？是的。好吧，很显然，邓德米夫林有大量的时间被浪费了。好吧，这就是为了让我们展示恶作剧的提示。是的，所有的吉姆和德怀特恶作剧。没错。当你观看这个汇编时，考虑到邓德米夫林是公司里业绩最好的分公司，真的非常迷人。埃里克的下一个问题是关于退休年龄的。有人接近邓德米夫林的退休年龄吗？珍娜，我从来没想过这个。比如，克里德一定到了退休年龄了。
Sure. He could probably resign and start receiving retirement benefits. Yeah. It seems like something Creed would want to do. Agree. He could go travel the world and get his checks, checking on his apartment in Canada. He has too many side hustles. He can't leave. I know. Who's going to like sell all of our equipment on the black market? Grow mung beans in their drawer. I mean, he needs to be there. It's also where he lives part time. Also, I feel like Creed is one of the only supporting cast members that got his own flashback clip segment. He kind of did. Well, our final flashback is going to be to flashback on all the romantic moments at Dunder Mufflin. Yes, because Michael is going to say that Dunder Mufflin is a place for lovers, basically.
当然。他可能可以辞职并开始领取退休福利。是的。这听起像是克里德会想做的事。同意。他可以去环游世界并拿到支票，顺便查看他在加拿大的公寓。他有太多的副业了。他不能离开。我知道。谁来在黑市上卖掉我们所有的设备？在抽屉里种绿豆？我是说，他需要留在那儿。这也是他半工半读住的地方。另外，我觉得克里德是唯一获得自己闪回剪辑片段的配角之一。他差不多算是有吧。好吧，我们的最后一段闪回将是回顾邓德米夫林的所有浪漫时刻。是的，因为迈克尔要说邓德米夫林基本上是一个适合恋人的地方。
Yes. Toby tells him it's inappropriate to speak about this, but Michael really wants Eric to know that this is a building where friends become lovers and lovers become sexually active. Sitting next to the human resources guy. So this montage backs up what we were saying the other week about how there are so many hookups at work. But I will say there is a moment missing from this montage, which is the Michael Holly stairwell hookup. And I would have liked to have had that in there. Agreed. Well, Eric's assessment of Dunder Mufflin is done. He's had, I think, probably way more than he needed to know about the company answered for him. It's time for him to go.
是的。托比告诉他谈论这个不合适，但迈克尔真的很想让埃里克知道，这是一栋朋友变成恋人、恋人开始有性生活的大楼。就坐在人力资源部的人旁边。所以这段蒙太奇印证了我们上周所说的话，关于工作中存在这么多的约会。但我必须要说，这段蒙太奇里少了一个时刻，那就是迈克尔和霍莉在楼梯间的约会。我本来很想把它放进去的。同意。好吧，埃里克对邓德米夫林的评估完成了。他得到了，我认为，比他需要了解的关于公司的信息多得多的解答。他该走了。
But we're going to end this episode with another flashback. It's Michael and Dwight doing the straight out of Scranton wrap. And it's the whole thing. That's right. This is the full extended cut. If you guys want to go rewatch it, it lives in this clip show. The full thing. And guys, that is the banker. We hope you learned a few things that you wouldn't have known otherwise. Here's something kind of dorky and rewatching it. Oh, this is so dorky. It made me miss early Jim and early Pam and the early days of the show, even though I'm really enjoying where we are in the show and everyone's character growth.
但我们要以另一段闪回结束这集。那是迈克尔和德怀特表演的《直接走出斯克兰顿说唱》。而且是整段的。没错。这是完整的加长剪辑版。如果你们想去重看，它就活在这个剪辑秀里。完整版。伙计们，这就是银行家。我们希望你们学到了一些原本不会知道的事情。这里有个重看时有点书呆子气的时刻。哦，这太书呆子气了。这让我怀念早期的吉姆和早期的帕姆以及节目的早期日子，尽管我真的很享受我们在节目中所处的位置和每个人的角色成长。
I did have this like longing of like, oh my gosh, I think I'm going to go back and rewatch those first early years. What is wrong with me? Well, lady, that's very sweet. I guess I'm just a dork for our own show. Well, listen, since we have time, I thought we could do a little housekeeping, maybe a little fan mail. Okay. So first off, we have a new clue in the steam town mall fountain case that we were working on as mom detectives. Do you remember? We were wondering, is there a fountain in the mall or not? Because Michael mentions it twice in Koi pond. He says he fell into it. And in double date, he fished a coin out for Helene scrapbook. Well, Cassie called the mall and some folks on our
我确实有一种这种渴望，就像，哦天哪，我想我要回去重看那些最初的早年岁月了。我怎么了？好吧，女士，这太甜蜜了。我想我只是对我们自己的节目有点书呆子气吧。好吧，听着，既然我们有时间，我想我们可以做点日常琐事，也许读点粉丝来信。好的。所以首先，我们在斯克兰顿商城喷泉案中有了一个新线索，我们在作为妈妈侦探时一直在调查。还记得吗？我们在想，商城里到底有没有喷泉？因为迈克尔在《锦鲤池》中提到了两次。他说他掉进去了。而在《双重约会》中，他为海伦的剪贴簿钓起了一枚硬币。好吧，卡西给商城打了电话，我们办公室
office Facebook page called the mall. These poor people at the mall. Remember, and the people at the mall were like, why does everyone keep calling and asking about fountains? And they said, no, that's what the mall said. There's no fountain here. Well, I don't know. We might have to reopen this case because Josiah Trudeau sent in a photo of what he is saying is the fountain at steam town mall. What? Yes. Apparently there was a fountain at the steam town mall, but they had to shut it down because of financial reasons. He said it is still there, but it is now filled with dirt and plants instead. So if you went there, it would just look like a giant planter. I have a picture. You can put it in office lady pod stories. I believe that people do that. I've done that.
Facebook 页面上的一些人也给商城打了电话。商城里的这些可怜人。记得吗，商城的人就说：为什么每个人都一直打电话来询问喷泉的事？他们说，不，那是商城说的。这里没有喷泉。好吧，我不知道。我们可能不得不重新审视这个案子，因为约西亚·特鲁多（Josiah Trudeau）发来了一张照片，照片上他说的那就是斯克兰顿商城的喷泉。什么？是的。显然斯克兰顿商城以前有一个喷泉，但由于财务原因他们不得不把它关掉了。他说它还在那儿，但现在里面填满了泥土和植物。所以如果你去那儿，它看起来就像一个巨大的花盆。我有一张照片。你可以把它发到办公室女士播客的故事里。我相信人们会这么做。我做过。
You've made a fountain into a planter. Yes. Where? Okay. So at our house, outside on our patio, there was a fountain. We actually put in the fountain when we redid our patio when we bought our house. We put in a fountain and it would get all mucky and then we had an infestation of mosquitoes and we would clean it out and we would try to filter it and we tried to keep this fountain going. And eventually we gave up and we drilled a hole into the bottom of it. We filled it with dirt and now there are plants in it. There's also a spout coming out above the plants, which was the fountain part. So it's a little odd, but yeah, now we have just plants. Yeah. I had some neighbors in their 60s who turned their hot tub into a flower bed.
你把一个喷泉变成了一个花盆。是的。在哪儿？好吧。所以在我们家里，外面我们的露台上，有一个喷泉。当我们买下房子重做露台时，我们实际上在里面装了一个喷泉。我们装了一个喷泉，它会变得一团糟，然后我们招来了蚊虫滋生，我们会把它清理干净，我们会试图过滤它，我们试图让这个喷泉继续运转。最终我们放弃了，我们在它的底部钻了个洞。我们用泥土把它填满，现在里面有植物了。植物上方还有一个喷出的喷嘴，也就是喷泉的部分。所以有点奇怪，但是是的，现在我们只有植物了。是的。我有一些60多岁的邻居把他们的热水浴缸变成了一个花坛。
Stop. No, they did. They said, you know what? We had a good time in that hot tub for years, but we're done going in hot tubs. We're done. And they made it into a planter. Huh? Mm-hmm. They said our hot tub days are over. I'm not going to argue with them. They're in their late 60s. They're done with it. They said they'd rather have flowers. I would have loved to see you argue with them. I wasn't going to argue with them. Well, if you thought that our mom detectiving was over, I have news for you. We have a client. We have a paying customer. Well, I don't know if they're paying. We have a customer. We have a customer, our first customer,
停下。不，他们真的这么做了。他们说，你知道吗？我们在那个热水浴缸里度过了一段美好的时光多年，但我们不再泡热水浴缸了。我们不泡了。他们把它变成了一个花盆。哈？嗯哼。他们说我们的热水浴缸日子结束了。我才不会跟他们争论。他们已经快70岁了。他们不玩那个了。他们说他们宁愿要花。我很想看你跟他们争论。我才不会跟他们争论呢。好吧，如果你以为我们的妈妈侦探工作已经结束了，我有个消息要告诉你。我们有一个客户。我们有一个付钱的客户。好吧，我不知道他们是不是付钱的。我们有一个客户。我们有一个客户，我们的第一个客户，
and our customer is none other than David Constable, aka the banker. What does he want us to find out? I'll let him tell you. I want to see, I want you guys, because you are the keepers of the Book of Knowledge about the show. Are there any other guest actors who have been in other projects with as many office regulars as I have? This is a question for you. This is a question that I'm posing to you, because Jenna, you and I did a movie together. John and I did a movie together. So I'm just saying, I'm not saying, I'm just saying. You tell me. Thank you guys. Good luck. Wait, is David like our Kevin Bacon? Is it like six degrees of David?
而我们的客户不是别人，正是大卫·科恩斯贝尔（David Constable），也就是银行家。他想让我们查出什么？我让他自己告诉你。我想看看，我想让你们，因为你们是关于这部剧的知识之书的守护者。还有没有哪个客串演员和其他多少办公室常驻演员合作过项目的作品和我一样多？这是一个问题。这是我向你们提出的问题，因为珍娜，你和我一起拍过电影。约翰和我一起拍过电影。所以我只是说，我不是那个意思，我只是说。你告诉我。谢谢你们。祝你好运。等等，大卫就像是我们的凯文·贝肯（Kevin Bacon）吗？这就像大卫的六度分隔理论吗？
I think a little bit. So let's find out, David. We're going to get on this. As I told you earlier, I did a movie with David, and the movie he's referring to that he did with John Krasinski was the Michael Bay movie 13 Hours, which also has David Denman in it. Now, David Denman was a recurring character, but I feel like he is part of our main office family. For sure. So I'm going to count him. Plus, David has worked with Rain in the past. So that is four cast members that I've counted so far. Now, we've enlisted Cassie again. Cassie. Cassie, part of the mom detective squad. Yeah, I'm a cat mom detective. But this is a very hard thing to figure out. I started asking myself,
我觉得有一点。所以让我们查一下，大卫。我们要开始调查了。正如我之前告诉你们的，我和大卫拍过电影，他提到的他和约翰·卡拉辛斯基一起拍的那部电影是迈克尔·贝的电影《危机13小时》，其中也有大卫·丹曼（David Denman）。现在，大卫·丹曼是一个常驻角色，但我觉得他是我们办公室大家庭的一部分。肯定的。所以我把它算上。另外，大卫过去曾和雷恩合作过。所以我到现在已经数出四个演员了。现在，我们再次把卡西招募进来了。卡西。卡西，妈妈侦探小队的成员。是的，我是一个猫妈侦探。但这真的很难搞清楚。我开始问自己，
what other guest stars have been on the show? This is a lot of data. Well, I thought of Will Ferrell because I had done a movie with Will and so had Steve. I wondered if anyone else had. I thought of Tim Meadows. Right. And I did a project with Tim Meadows and Rob Riggle, a TV show. Oh, and then Rob Riggle has worked with so many people on the show. But Cassie did a real deep dive and thought of someone that I had not thought of. Cassie, what'd you find? Yeah. And first off, shout out to the Office Ladies Facebook fan page, especially Susan A, for all your help. And I'll just say, I only did movies. I feel like I have
还有哪些客串明星上过这档节目？这有大量的数据。好吧，我想到了威尔·法瑞尔（Will Ferrell），因为我和威尔拍过电影，史蒂夫也是。我在想还有没有其他人。我想到了蒂姆·梅多斯（Tim Meadows）。对。我和蒂姆·梅多斯以及罗布·里格尔（Rob Riggle）合作过一个项目，一个电视剧。哦，然后罗布·里格尔和剧里的很多人合作过。但卡西进行了非常深入的挖掘，想到了一个我没有想到的人。卡西，你找到了什么？是的。首先，向办公室女士 Facebook 粉丝专页大喊，特别是苏珊·A（Susan A），感谢你的所有帮助。我要说的是，我只查了电影。我觉得我
to do this again with adding TV shows. Okay. But this person has been in eight movies with eight different office cast members. Who? Will Arnett. Will Arnett. Yes. Will Arnett comes in to interview to be the new boss at Dunder Mifflin as part of search committee. Oh my gosh. I forgot about that. And I think that's maybe the winner. I think so. The runner-ups I have right now are Ken John. He had seven movies and then Amy Adams had six. Okay. Wow. Yeah. I did a movie with Ken. Crazy. So tell us, who did Will Arnett do projects with? Yeah. So Jenna, he did Blades of Glory with you. Yes. With Ed Holmes, he did Semi-Pro. Then with both Steve and Mindy, Despicable Me, John, brief interviews with hideous men,
必须把电视剧也加进去再做一次。好的。但这个人曾与八个不同的办公室演员一起出演过八部电影。谁？威尔·阿奈特（Will Arnett）。威尔·阿奈特。是的。威尔·阿奈特作为搜寻委员会成员之一，来面试邓德米夫林的新老板。哦，天哪。我把这事给忘了。我觉得这也许是赢家。我也这么觉得。我目前知道的亚军是郑肯（Ken Jeong）。他拍了七部电影，然后安妮·海瑟薇——不，是艾米·亚当斯（Amy Adams）有六部。好的。哇。是的。我和郑肯拍过电影。太疯狂了。所以告诉我们，威尔·阿奈特和谁合作过项目？是的。所以珍娜，他和你在《荣誉之刃》里合作过。是的。与埃德·霍尔姆斯，他合作了《半职业选手》。然后与史蒂夫和明迪两人一起，神偷奶爸。约翰，简短采访丑陋的人，
Brian Rumble, Rain, Monsters First Aliens, LaLaura, the Comebacks. Wow. Okay. Ken Jong was the runner-up with seven. He was also in Despicable Me with Steve and Mindy. He was in the Muppets with John. He's in the Hangover with Ed, Knocked Up with BJ, Furry Vengeance with Angela, and he did Pineapple Express and Knocked Up with Craig. Oh. Well, David, I'm sorry to say. It looks like maybe. Will Arnett beat you? Yeah. And Ken Jong. Yeah. Cassie, great work. Thanks. Maybe one day I'll try TV shows too, but my brain was already hurting. Well, it's finally time for us to answer the quiz. Remember the quiz I put at the top of the show? Oh, yes. Well, here it is. How many episodes do you think made up the banker? Okay, I don't know the answer, but I did watch
布莱恩·兰布尔（Brian Rumble），雷恩，怪兽大战外星人，拉劳拉，《飞人前传》。哇。好吧。郑肯以七部屈居亚军。他也和史蒂夫和明迪一起出演了《神偷奶爸》。他和约翰一起出演了《布偶寻宝记》。他在《宿醉》里搭档埃德，在《一夜大肚》里搭档B·J，在《毛茸茸的复仇》里搭档安吉拉，他和克雷格一起出演了《菠萝快车》和《一夜大肚》。哦。好吧，大卫，我很抱歉这么说。看起来也许。威尔·阿奈特击败了你？是的。还有郑肯。是的。卡西，干得漂亮。谢谢。也许有一天我也会尝试电视剧，但我的大脑已经开始痛了。好吧，终于到了我们回答小测验的时候了。还记得我在节目开头出的那个测验吗？哦，是的。好吧，就是这个。你觉得有多少集构成了《银行家》？好吧，我不知道答案，但我的确看了
the episode and I know that the banker was, you know, we'd done over a hundred episodes by the time this clip show happened. So I'm gonna say maybe 40 different episodes? There were 63 episodes used in this clip show. Wow, 63. Yeah. They almost got a clip from every episode up to this point. I'm pretty impressed. Two thirds. Yeah. Very good work. Well, we are going to wrap up this episode with a little digital clutter and some more fan mail. Yes. Here's a little something from my digital clutter. Angela's digital clutter. Makes me happy every time. Every time. All right. So as you guys know, by now, that we only worked two days on this episode. And I found in my digital clutter that my daughter Isabel and I had a play date, Jenna, at your house during the week of the
这一集，我知道《银行家》这一集播出时，你知道的，当这个剪辑秀发生时，我们已经拍了一百多集了。所以我猜大概有40个不同的剧集？这个剪辑秀里使用了63集。哇，63集。是的。他们几乎从截至目前每集里都截取了一个剪辑片段。我印象相当深刻。三分之二。是的。干得非常漂亮。好吧，我们要用一点数字杂物和更多的粉丝来信来结束这一集。好的。这里有一点来自我的数字杂物。安吉拉的数字杂物。每次都让我开心。每次。好了。所以正如你们所知，到目前为止，我们这集只拍了两天。我在我的数字杂物里发现，珍娜，在拍摄这集的那个星期，我的女儿伊莎贝尔（Isabel）和你进行了一次约玩。好的。是的。那是星期二下午，伊莎贝尔和我过来跟你一起玩。然后就在同一个星期，你给我发了一电子邮件，主题是：我可能坠入爱河了。那就是主题栏。当时我就想，什么？当我打开电子邮件时，是一张你和一只可爱小猫的照片。哦，是的。那一定是我在寄养邓德（Dunder）和米夫林（Mifflin）的时候。嗯哼。我有那张照片。太可爱了。我会把它发到故事里。好吧，我在翻看我们的一些信件，这封真的让我印象深刻。这封信来自来自八个不同州的娜塔莉（Natalie）。哦，我们的表单上有一个字段，你可以填写真实来自哪里。她写道，我过去几年在八个不同的州生活过。我都不知道该说我来自哪里。
filming of this episode. Okay. Yes. It was a Tuesday afternoon and Isabel and I came over and hung out with you. And then this same week, you emailed me saying, I might have fallen in love. That was the subject field. And I was like, what? And when I opened the email, it was a picture of you in an adorable kitten. Oh, yes. So that must have been when I was fostering Dunder and Mifflin. Uh-huh. I have the picture. It's so cute. I'll put it in stories. Well, I was going through some of our mail and this one really stuck out to me. This one is from Natalie from eight different states. Oh, we have a field on our form where you can fill in where you're from. And she had written, I have lived in eight different states in the past few years. I don't know where to say I'm from.
我们拍摄这一集的时候。好的。是的。那是周二下午，伊莎贝尔和我过来陪你。然后就在同一周，你给我发了一封邮件，主题是“我可能恋爱了”。当时我就想，什么？当我打开邮件时，那是你和一只可爱小猫的照片。哦，对。所以那一定是我在寄养邓德和米夫林的时期。嗯哼。我有那张照片。它太可爱了。我会把它发到快拍里。嗯，我在整理我们的一些信件时，这封特别吸引我。这封信来自来自八个不同州的娜塔莉。哦，我们的表单上有一个字段，你可以填写你来自哪里。她写道，我在过去几年里在八个不同的州生活过。我都不知道该说自己是哪里的。
Oh, so Natalie from eight different states wrote, this isn't so much a question but a thank you. I wanted to say I've been loving my escape my me time while listening to the office ladies. I started a couple of months ago after being a huge office fan for years and it's just been so great. I've been a stay at home mom for four years while traveling with my family. It's amazing, but lonely too. I've never been away from my toddler and I haven't had a babysitter in a year and a half. I love my toddler and our unconventional life, but in many ways it's been very hard on me emotionally and mentally. The time I get to listen to the show, usually when cooking dinner, makes me feel like a person again outside of motherhood and feels like I'm listening to good
哦，来自八个不同州的娜塔莉写道，这与其说是一个问题，不如说是一个感谢。我想说，在收听《办公室女士》的同时，我一直很享受我的逃离时光，我的me time。几个月前，在成为多年的办公室铁粉后，我开始收听，这真的是太棒了。我当了四年全职妈妈，同时和家人一起旅行。这很神奇，但也同样孤独。我从来没有离开过我的幼儿，而且我已经一年半没有请过保姆了。我爱我的幼儿和我们这种非传统的生活，但在许多方面，它在情感和精神上对我非常艰难。我收听节目的时间，通常是在做晚饭时，让我感觉自己除了母亲身份之外，又重新成为了一个人，感觉就像是在听好
friends. Thanks. Oh, Natalie. Natalie, I'm so glad we could be there with you. Yeah, absolutely. I totally understand the loneliness that happens when you are staying home with your very young children. That is so normal. Those feelings, you know, you are giving everything you can to raising this little person. And you're happy too. That's the thing. You're so happy to be doing that, but you definitely miss like adult conversation and seeing people, but yet your heart and everything that you want to be doing is right there at home. Well, when my husband Lee travels for work, the thing that I say to him that I miss the most is our adult conversation. Because when you're with little kids, it's all little kid conversation, little kid activities. And I miss even just
朋友聊天。谢谢。哦，娜塔莉。娜塔莉，我很高兴我们能陪伴着你。是的，绝对的。我完全理解当你呆在家照顾非常小的孩子时发生的那种孤独感。那是太正常的感受了。那些感觉，你知道的，你把你能付出的一切都奉献给了抚养这个小人儿。而且你也很高兴。事情就是这样。你很高兴能这样做，但你绝对会想念成年人的谈话和见到人们的感觉，然而你的心以及你想要做的所有事情就都在家里。好吧，当我的丈夫李（Lee）出差工作时，我对他说我想念得最多的就是我们的成年人交谈。因为当你和小孩子在一起时，全都是小孩子的话题、小孩子活动的。甚至连我们说“哦，嘿，你听了这个播客吗？或者你读了这篇东西吗？”我都觉得怀念，或者只是微小的成年人社交互动时刻。所以我完全能理解这封信，因为当他去旅行时，而我没怎么跟他联系，你知道，由于出差的性质，那就是我会一头扎进狂看《Bitch Sesh》（一档播客），只是听朋友们闲聊成年人的事情，你知道的，或者我会听一堆最好的朋友。我如此倾向于这些播客来填补那种孤独。你的成年人时间。是的。我完全理解。所以谢谢娜塔莉的来信。好吧，我们还有一封来自德克萨斯州和加利福尼亚州的艾比（Abby）的信。艾比写道，与其说是一个问题，不如说是一个感谢。最近去世的祖母和我总是互称“女士”。
us saying, oh, hey, did you listen to this podcast? Or did you read this thing? Or just the little adult social interaction moments. So I totally related to this letter because when he goes on trips, and I'm not in touch with him as much, you know, by the nature of someone traveling for work, that is when I will dive into just binging bitch sesh, just listening to friends, chitty chat about adult things, you know, or I'll listen to a bunch of best friends. I so gravitate toward these podcasts to fill that loneliness. Your adult time. Yeah. I totally get that. So thanks, Natalie, for your letter. Well, we had another letter from Abby from Texas and California. Abby writes, not so much a question as a thank you. My grandma who recently passed away and I would call each other lady.
我们说，哦，嘿，你听过这个播客吗？或者你看过这个吗？或者只是那些微小的成年人社交互动时刻。所以我完全能理解这封信，因为当他去旅行时，我和他的联系没那么多了，你知道的，因为出差的性质，那就是我会沉浸于狂听《Bitch Sesh》，听朋友们闲聊成年人的事，你知道的，或者我会听一堆《Best Friends》。我非常倾向于通过这些播客来填补这种孤独感。你的成年人时间。是的。我完全理解。所以谢谢娜塔莉的来信。嗯，我们还有一封来自德克萨斯和加利福尼亚的艾比的信。艾比写道，与其说是问题，不如说是感谢。我最近去世的奶奶和我以前会互相叫女士。
I don't know where it started or why, but it was always a name that only she and I would call one another. I'm reminded of her every time you guys lady one another, and I could not be more grateful. Thank you for the sweet reminders and thank you for staying true to what gives your friendship its own flavor. What a treasure. Thank you again, sweet office ladies. I love that. Oh, Abby, lady, we love you. We sure do, lady. Well, there you have it. That is our episode today. A big thank you to David Constable, Rob Burnett and Randy Cordray for helping us get all the info we needed for this one. That's right. And a big thank you to Cassie, our new mom detective assistant. And Sam, always for your loving voice that pops in to share what not with us.
我不知道它是从哪里开始的，也不知道为什么，但它一直是一个只有她和我才会互称的名字。每当你们互称“女士”时，我都会想起她，我对此感激不尽。谢谢你们带来这些甜蜜的回忆，也谢谢你们忠于赋予你们友谊独特风味的本质。多么宝贵的财富。再次感谢你们，甜蜜的办公室女士。我太喜欢了。哦，艾比，女士，我们爱你。我们当然爱你，女士。好吧，事情就是这样。这就是我们今天的节目。非常感谢大卫·科恩斯贝尔、罗布·内特（应为罗布·伯内特）和罗恩·科德雷帮我们找到了这集所需的所有信息。没错。非常感谢卡西，我们的新妈妈侦探助理。还有萨姆，总是用你充满爱意的声音插进来和我们分享各种小事。
Our pleasure. All right, we hope you have a great week. We will see you next time. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubico. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
不客气。好的，希望你们有一个美好的一周。我们下期再见。回头见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由 Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔执行制作。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的声音工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉特因的《橡胶树》。有关《办公室女士》的无广告版本，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。有关 Stitcher Premium 的免费一个月的试用，请使用代码：OFFICE。这集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子来留下评论。